sa silhouette fine et sa moustache
naissante ali reza est encore un
adolescent
mais à 16 ans ce jeune iranien fait déjà
partie des 40 meilleurs joueurs d'échecs
au monde
cette passion est née quand il avait 8
ans grâce à son frère aîné faisait
beaucoup de sport l'été du football du
basket mais un jour je suis allé au club
d'échecs de ma ville en iran et
l'atmosphère était géniale la balle et
depuis je joue aux échecs
on travaille ce sont les échecs
je pense à ça tout le temps après avoir
suivi un programme d'entraînement
spécial en iran il a décidé avec sa
famille de quitter téhéran pour
s'installer en france à chartres pendant
un an où il compte améliorer son niveau
ici pas d'école il ne fera que jouer aux
échecs
entraînés par un grand maître azéri du
club qui va partager avec lui son
expérience la meilleure note fort
tonnage se trouvent en europe en ce
moment donc est pour ça qu elle cette
occasion qui veulent profiter à les
raisins pour déjà comme on adhère le
plein air dans la première tournée lgv
entre dans le top 10 mondial
mais bien sûr qu'on espère qu'elle va il
va faire muer il voit tv le champion de
monde ravi d'attirer une telle pépite
dans l'équipe d'échec le club et la
mairie ont d'ailleurs soutenu ali reza
et sa famille dans leur démarche ses
parents et son frère ont en effet choisi
de le suivre
je vais m'adapter avec mon entreprise en
iran pour pouvoir travailler à distance
depuis charest à peine arrivé alireza va
déjà s'envoler le 8 septembre pour la
russie pour y disputer la coupe du monde
d'échecs une qualification rare pour un
jeune de son âge